est ta saison c'était avec fx françois
xavier était très aimée avec lui et on
sait que françois xavier s'est suicidé
s'est jeté sous une voiture on passe pas
d'image tout ça on n'a pas envie mais
qu'est ce que ça t'a inspiré après ce
que tu t'es dit justement que vous étiez
pas assez préparée est ce que tu t'es tu
attends a voulu à quelqu'un à la prod
est ce que tu as qu'est-ce que ça c'est
qu'est ce que ça dit de cette génération
ben elle fait que c'était quelqu'un qui
déjà avait une faiblesse avant de
rentrer dans le jeu c'est à dire que
j'étais déjà très jeune à la légère
voilà il avait des problèmes de drogue
avant de rentrer dans l'émission voilà
il était issu d'une famille quand même
très aisés qui bon ok c'est ce qu'ils
pouvaient mais voilà dans un milieu où
il avait accès à plus facilement à jean
de déviance et je pense que la notoriété
l'a pas aidé peut-être avoir une
reconnaissance dans sa famille voilà
c'était une reconnaissance qu'il avait
besoin
fx enfin voilà il me manque beaucoup et
c'est vrai que quand il ya eu la pelota
lumière s'est arrêtée parce qu'a eu
cette émission ensuite qui est parti qui
a pas marché du tout pardon c'est long
carré vip chez calais quand la lumière
s'est un peu arrêté sur lui l'a très mal
vécu c'est dans ces moments qu'on se dit
est-ce que c'est pas dans ces moments où
l'appareil pour loana ou cocktail
lumière s'arrête c'est là où il faudrait
peut-être soutenir ceux qui sont les
plus faibles la lumière s'arrête
forcément au bout d'un moment c'est pour
ça qu'on court vite à faire plein de
projets on sort d'une émission comme ça
c'est ce que j'ai fais d'ailleurs après
quand on est trop jeune et quand on fait
ce genre d'émission c'est sûr que c'est
difficile après de se relever et de se
dire que non mais c'est pas la vraie vie
quand la neige avait 25 ans 26 ans quand
la feci crête vont elles étaient déjà
plus mature moi j'avais 26 ans quand je
suis rentré dans le sucre est on sait
que la vraie vie c'est pas la célébrité
on sait que moi à chaque fois que je
faisais mais tout ce que j'ai fait après
secrète pour moi c'était du jeu j'ai
jamais rien pris au sérieux et encore
aujourd'hui mais la célébrité c'est pour
de faux pour moi en fait et lui il a
vraiment cru que les gens qu'il aimait
les musulmans les gens qui ne le
regardait plus n'est laid mais plus tu
vois donc c'était un peu l'enfant maudit
c'est de se faire voilà de se faire
remarquer pour son leica avant qu'on a
sur le bovidé ans qu'est la très sage et
tout ça et c'est sur quoi on va aller à
quelques questions pour l'épauler petit
show qui sont très beaux est-ce que vous
et ses proches de la famille daffix ou
pas du tout j'ai eu un petit banc si je
devais reprocher quelque chose avec
quelqu'un c'est que quand fx tu vois il
nous a quittés déjà moi j'avais du mal à
balle assimilé parce que ma quand tu
quelqu'un de ton entourage proche parent
en fait c'est important d'aller surnom à
l'enterrement et voilà le le voir quoi
enfin voilà et en fait ils ont refusé
que l'on soit là nous ses amis proches
donc moi ça ça m'a été enfin je les
malpris moi je voulais après le décès d
fixe j'ai voulu bas répondre à es6 de ce
qu'il aurait voulu et il voulait qu'on
parle de lui partout donc j'ai accepté
absolument toutes les interviews dans
tous les magazines parce que pour moi je
c'était pour lui que je faisais vous
n'aviez aucun suivi psychologiquement
avait ainsi que j'aurais comparé dont je
n'incarne moi c'est vrai qu'après on
reparte sur dur du vivian est d'accord
la psychologie qu après voilà il ya des
gens qui nous appellent qui prennent de
nouvelles voilà qu'on dise que y'a pas
dessus psychologiquement les gens ils
peuvent pas vivre avec nous enfin le
dire à un moment donné on prend l'eau
très lucide
on fait notre vie mais il ya lazuli